INTRO:
Toyota was one of the first automakers to
embrace an EV future.
I mean, how could anyone forget the iconic
Toyota Prius.
The Prius didn’t have the best of social
images, but it was and still is one of the
most cost effective vehicles on the road.
Aside from pioneering the way with hybrids,
Toyota was also an early investor in Tesla.
Way back in 2010, Toyota invested $50 million
into Tesla which gave them a 1.43% stake in
the company.
If they were still holding this stake, it
would be worth over $10 billion, but unfortunately,
they sold this stake in mid 2017.
At the time, it seemed like Toyota was simply
taking risk off the table and locking in profits,
but looking back, it seems like something
changed with Toyota as they sold off this
stake.
Since then, Toyota has actually become more
of an EV opposer.
For example, Toyota has actually been lobbying
to slow down the move to EVs.
They’ve also been behind the curve when
it comes to fully electric vehicles.
It wasn’t till April of 2022 that they released
their first fully electric SUV onto the market.
And they’ve actually recalled this vehicle
due the wheels falling off, so it’s not
exactly going great.
Now, supporters of Toyota would probably point
out that Toyota is investing a significant
amount into battery technology.
For instance, they have a plan to invest $13.5
billion into battery tech by the end of the
decade.
But, compared to the rest of the industry,
this is rather underwhelming.
Take Ford for example.
Ford is literally drowning in debt with over
$200 billion in liabilities.
Yet, they just increased their EV investment
from $30 billion through 2026 to $50 billion.
Similarly, Volkswagen is investing $180 billion
into EVs over the next 4 years.
Considering these investments, Toyota’s
commitment is rather underwhelming.
Clearly, they haven’t ditched EVs altogether,
but at the same time, they’re also refusing
to go all in and jump onto the EV bandwagon.
So, why is Toyota so hesitant with EVs?
HYDROGEN:
One of the main reasons Toyota has been so
hesitant when it comes to EVs is because they’ve
been betting on hydrogen.
According to Toyota’s Vice chairman, they
“don’t want to be seen as an EV maker,
but as a carbon-neutral company.”
Toyota argues that this carbon neutral future
does not have to be achieved with EVs.
“Carbon neutrality is not about one having
a single choice, but about keeping options
open.”
This in itself is not a bad stance per se,
but thus far, we’ve only seen issues when
it comes to hydrogen vehicles.
Take the 2021 Tokyo Olympics for example.
Toyota supplied the Olympics with 500 hydrogen
busses and cars.
The vehicles themselves worked alright, but
the same could not be said about the finances.
You see, Toyota leased out these busses to
Japan for $900,000 for 6 years.
A comparable diesel bus could have been leased
out for $220,000 for 15 years.
On an annual basis, the hydrogen bus works
out to $150,000 per year while the diesel
bus works out to under $15,000 per year.
In other words, the hydrogen option is literally
10 times as expensive, and that’s just the
lease.
Unlike EVs where fueling up is dramatically
cheaper than gas counterparts, with these
hydrogen busses, it’s actually 2.6 times
more expensive.
If you thought EVs were already expensive,
these are clearly on a different level.
To make things worse, financial concerns are
just the first of your worries.
Hydrogen vehicles also suffer from an extremely
underdeveloped refueling network.
Unlike electric charging, you can’t just
setup a few charging stations that link up
to the local power grid.
Instead, you have to buy hydrogen specific
fuel dispensers that often cost $100,000 per
unit.
You also have to spend a significant amount
on storing the hydrogen and you also have
to deal with regular hydrogen deliveries.
In other words, you basically have to run
a gas station.
And given that the majority of gas stations
make their money off of the convenience stores
attached to the gas stations, I don’t think
they’ll be particularly thrilled to invest
into hydrogen infrastructure.
One advantage that should be pointed out,
however, is that filling up a hydrogen vehicle
is similar to filling up a gas vehicle meaning
that you can get a full tank of gas within
just 3 to 5 minutes.
If you’re someone who does a lot of road
trips, this is likely a significant advantage,
but that’s pretty much where the advantages
end.
It’s not just the fueling process that’s
similar between gas vehicles and hydrogen
vehicles.
The maintenance process is also quite similar.
You see, hydrogen vehicles are way more complex
than EVs meaning that they naturally come
along with more maintenance given that more
things can go wrong.
So, from a big picture view, hydrogen vehicles
cost more, they require more maintenance,
and the infrastructure is the least developed,
so hydrogen vehicles just don’t stack up
against EVs.
But then why is Toyota so determined to go
down this path?
Well, the answer seems to lie in what’s
best for Japan as opposed to what’s best
for everyone.
JAPAN’S ENERGY CRISIS:
Japan’s obsession with hydrogen is nothing
new.
In fact, it’s just one of many avenues that
Japan has been experimenting with for decades.
And the main reason the country doesn’t
want to bend to western standards is because
of the country’s energy dependence.
Japan is basically just an island which means
that they don’t have any neighboring countries.
At first glance, this might seem cool.
They have this entire piece of land all to
themselves.
But, logistically, this is actually a nightmare.
Here’s the thing, when you aren’t physically
attached to any other countries, shipping
becomes extremely difficult because everything
has to be shipping through the sea.
And this is especially a problem when we’re
talking about energy.
You see, much of the world either creates
their own energy or they rely on neighboring
countries.
Europe for example used to rely on Russia
for crude oil and natural gas.
They had a massive set of pipelines that facilitated
the trades between the two regions.
A similar case can be seen with America as
well.
Canada is the largest energy exporter to America
and the reasoning is obvious.
The two countries are touching which makes
it easy to trade energy.
Japan obviously doesn't have any such partners.
They also don’t have any of the high demand
resources like crude oil or natural gas.
So, they’ve essentially been forced into
importing all of their energy.
This is not only expensive, but it also puts
Japan at a massive trading disadvantage.
I mean, when you’re importing 94% of your
energy, you’re not exactly in the best position
to implement tariffs or start a trade war.
The other countries could hit back with an
energy boycott, and you’re country would
be screwed within a matter of days.
Japan is obviously not a fan of this situation
and they’ve been trying to escape this situation
for decades.
Their initial solution to this conundrum was
going all in on nuclear energy and this was
actually playing out really well.
At their peak in 2010, they were able to produce
13% of the entire country’s energy needs
using nuclear power.
But, all of this would come crashing down
in 2011 with the Fukushima Nuclear disaster.
You probably heard about this on the news.
154,000 people had to be evacuted and it’s
ranked as the second worst nuclear disaster
of all time, only beaten out by Chernobyl.
The worst part is that Japan couldn’t even
do anything about it.
It’s not like the disaster was caused mismanagement
or negligence.
It was actually caused by a record breaking
earthquake plus tsunami combination.
Really, the only way Japan could’ve avoided
this disaster was to not support nuclear energy
in the first place.
And that’s exactly what they’ve been trying
to do eversince, but this has catapulted the
entire country into a perpetual energy crisis.
Nowadays, its extremely common for Japan to
issue power conservation messages to households
and companies as the country is constantly
fighting to avoid blackouts.
As you would guess, Japan has been frantically
looking for solutions eversince the disaster,
and one of the top solutions that they’ve
landed on is hydrogen.
A SAVIOR:
While Japan doesn’t have access to any of
the common sources of energy, what they do
have access to is Hydrogen.
For once, Japan’s ocean surroundings are
actually helpful.
You see, the ocean floor surrounding Japan
is filled with a sherbert like substance often
referred to as “fire ice”.
These ice crystals hold a tremendous amount
of natural methane which can be converted
into even more hydrogen.
It’s estimated that just one cubic meter
of methane hydrate can produce 160 cubic meters
of methane gas which can then be turned into
hydrogen.
And given that Japan has an exclusive economic
zone that stretches to both sides of the country,
they have access to plenty of “fire ice”.
Now, it’s not all sunshines and rainbows
given that it’s not easy to extract “fire
ice”.
First, you have to voyage out deep into the
ocean where the sea floor is a 1000 meters
under the surface.
From there, you have to drill hundreds of
meters into the sea bed to actually retrieve
the “fire ice”.
Japan has been working on a new drilling method
that can potentially extract “fire ice”
from shallower locations and then send them
through underwater pipelines, but this is
still a work in progress.
It’s not clear if this new process will
work out, but it doesn’t matter whether
it does or not.
For the first time in a long time, Japan actually
has an alternative form of energy.
And if this process doesn’t work out, they’re
just gonna keep trying different processes
until they figure out something that does
work.
For them, this is not a matter of, “oh let’s
switch renewable energy because it’s the
right thing to do and it’s trendy”.
No, for them, this is a matter of “we have
to figure this out ASAP if we want to save
Japan from the energy crisis.”
So, they’ve obviously taking this extremely
seriously, and as Japan’s largest company,
Toyota is obviously doing everything they
can to support this vision.
And yes, that includes lobbying other countries
to slow down EV adoption.
When you look at it from the western perspective,
it seems like Toyota are the bad guys who
are teaming up with the oil giants like Shell
and Exxon to stall this wholesome movement
towards EVs, but that’s not really the case
at all.
Toyota isn’t against renewable energy or
EVs, they’re simply trying to promote the
form of energy that would be most beneficial
for their own country.
ONE SHOT:
Global energy changes don’t happen often.
If anything, they might happen once a century.
So, we’re truly living through historic
times, and Japan only has one shot at getting
this right.
Either they convince the world that hydrogen
is worth perusing right now, or they get left
behind as the entire world switches to EVs.
If this happens, Japan would just become even
more dependent on the rest of the world for
energy imports.
Also, allocating a significant portion of
their electricity towards running electric
cars will simply increase their chances of
a blackout even more.
So, that’s the last thing Japan wants to
do.
Something else that we should note is that
Japan is not even the country that would benefit
most from a switch to hydrogen.
It’s not like Japan has so much hydrogen
that they would become the next Saudi Arabia
or something.
Rather, a trend towards hydrogen would simply
alleviate their dependency for energy.
The country that would really profit from
this shift is China who is the leader in hydrogen
production and consumption.
China’s current hydrogen usage comes in
at a whopping 24 million tonnes per year.
Now, it should be noted that most of this
hydrogen is “grey” hydrogen meaning that
it’s produced using fossil fuels.
But, China is setting up loads of “green”
hydrogen plants as we speak, so they would
be the ones that would benefit most from such
a transition.
So, in the end, why is Toyota refusing to
jump onto the EV bandwagon despite pioneering
the industry?
Well, their home country, Japan has been struggling
with energy for decades, and there has been
a glimmer of hope with hydrogen.
So, they’re trying their best to leverage
this opportunity and maximize the benefit
for Japan, but only time will tell if this
gamble will be worth it.
Now that you see it from Japan’s perspective,
do you think Toyota is doing the wrong thing?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you hope that Japan is
able to overcome their energy crisis.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.